you
hi everyone it's Jerry this is video 18
from the beginner to chess master
playlist which is a progressive series
of videos and I have a quick little end
game technique to share with you this is
a technique I'm revisiting specifically
for this playlist you may recall it from
a couple years back I have exactly three
examples to share with you in this
position it's white to move and the big
question is can the White King catch the
black pawn will he be there in time
let's say so I'll throw it to you if
you'd like to go ahead pause the video
will the white king be able to track
that pawn down okay the answer is yes
and we can see that by mapping out the
moves
sure enough the white King will be there
in time to successfully track the pond
down there are a couple approaches we
could have taken to figure this out
one is to count one two three four five
one two three four five white would be
on move at that point going from G to
and then making the capture on the h1
square so we could have counted we could
have maybe visualized
both pieces moving or maybe you know
some combination of the two I don't use
either approach I don't count
I don't visualize so what approach do I
take well whether it's a slower game or
a faster game this is the approach or
this is the technique that I use when is
the Kings turn to move what I do is
envision that just for a moment the pawn
is a bishop and I draw a diagonal down
towards the promotion rank so this is
the diagonal that I'm referring to and
this is the diagonal of the following
square or box now this box is
significant because if I could answer
the simple question can the King enter
the box and by enter the box I mean to
be anywhere on the edge or inside of the
box if the King could enter the box and
he can well he can now
catch the pond if the king could enter
the box he will be able to catch the
pond so we're notice we're not counting
we're not visualizing both pieces moving
we're just doing a little artwork
drawing in a diagonal and the box
connected with it if the king could
enter the box he can catch the pawn it's
as simple as that let's have a look at
just our second of three examples once
again white to move go ahead and use
that technique and see if you can
quickly answer this one can the King
catch the pawn okay the answer to this
is no and keep in mind we go ahead and
draw in that diagonal in the Box
connected with it when it is the Kings
turn to move so it is the King's turn to
move here this is the diagonal this is
the box connected with it can the King
edge of the box
unfortunately no also bear in mind that
whenever that pawn makes a move we can
revisit that same question in this
position it's White's move
the new box here is this one can the
King enter that box it's getting smaller
once again he's not able to enter it he
will not be there in time to track the
pond down let's have a look at just one
more example this one right here where
it is now black to move if you like to
go ahead pause the video will the white
king be able to catch the black pawn ok
the answer to this is no keep in mind we
go ahead and draw in that box when it is
the King's turn to move in this position
it's black on move after h5 now we go
ahead and draw the diagonal and the box
connected with it can the King enter the
box unfortunately he cannot therefore he
will not be able to successfully track
down that pawn in time so as mentioned
this is something that I use whether it
be a slower game or a faster game it's a
very useful technique it'll save us at
least just a little bit on some of our
calculation workload just a nice little
trick to be familiar with so that's all
I have for you in this one as usual I
hope you got something out of it and
I'll catch you in the next one that's
all for now take care bye
you